the Toronto Raptors won the NBA
championship on Thursday night in the
last basketball game ever played at
Oracle Arena in Oakland California
obviously the Golden State Warriors were
hoping to win Game six and force a game
7 in Toronto but Toronto wins the last
game played there making it a very
memorable final game although for the
Canadian team and that led to our
inspiration for today's draft the most
memorable final games ever played at an
NFL stadium any NFL stadium last game
ever played their memorable is what
matters doesn't matter who wins or loses
what matters is how memorable it is big
cat you get the call tails the rigged
coin toss will go in your favor because
you haven't been on the show for a month
and you'll get the most obvious first
pick whichever it may be go ahead all
right I'll take tails there we go no
drama no suspense whatsoever as the coin
lands on tails and of course it was
gonna be tails all along all right
there's some good ones here I know you
do your research and I think you'll
agree with me there are some excellent
choices and I have a feeling you're also
gonna have a few curveballs that you're
ready to throw at me but go ahead
no curveballs because I got the first
pick and that just wins the draft on its
own so number one it's the easiest one I
think we both know what I'm using with
is it yeah are you yes it is one of the
most memorable games in NFL history
started a for Dinah Ste it's the Tuck
rule it's the Patriots in the Foxboro
Stadium that is the easiest pick and you
know it you know that losing that coin
toss lost you this draft I don't even
have to do the rest of the draft you
know and I've really thought there was a
chance that you were gonna consider
another final game just just because of
the of the it did what it's not a
football reason it was when the Browns
up and now look I let me let me let me
before I get to my pick I agree with you
yeah mobile game Foxborough stating the
last game played there the snow the kick
the Tuck roll everything about it
magical night for the Patriots and and
yes the birth of a dynasty okay and that
that's the obvious first choice but you
still had to at least do I don't at
least wonder about the last game in
Cleveland for the original Cleveland
Browns when they tore up memorials
Stadium and it was just a debacle and
the Browns players you know hey baby
said the buckling kind of a good way
except for you know they were throwing
stuff on the field and they were ripping
out full rows of seats but that last
game in Cleveland and the build-up to
that last game and I think it's one of
the reasons why teams are very careful
about when they pull the plug on when
they're moving nobody nobody really
wants to now the Raiders have gone three
years maybe they figured by the time
three years rolls around people will
process their their feelings of despair
but the last thing you want to do is
make it known in November of a football
season that you're leaving at the end of
that year because you set the stage for
the kind of craziness that we haven't
seen since the Browns the original
Browns now the Ravens played their last
game at Memorial Stadium in Cleveland so
that's my first-round pick Mike that
wasn't even in consideration for my
second pick and I think I me and oh I
haven't written down I'll show you I
have that written down that's why I mean
you're you that's why I'm smart and you
are dumb I have the Fox to pick one
power here go ahead easy number two also
easy the last game at the vet in
Philadelphia it was the NFC Championship
game the Bucs beat the Eagles go on to
win the Superbowl and it was a time when
the Eagles obviously they didn't have
they didn't have a Super Bowl you know
title they were knocking on the door the
Donovan McNabb Eagles also what that
stadium was and what it meant to old
school football it was that old turf
that was terrible it was like one of the
last turfs like that to go out the vet
had some unbelievable memories they had
the jail inside like the Eagles fans
where Philadelphia and their fan base
are born is the 300 level of that
stadium that is an easy number to and it
was an NFC Championship game we're not
talking about a regular season game like
in Cleveland I just gave you two playoff
games an NFC championship game last game
in Philadelphia at the vet that one's
more memorable if the Eagles win it they
lost to the Buccaneers
memorable I understand I understand the
most memorable final game
I'm telling you that game is more
memorable if the home team wins it
that's the point it's not like they won
the Superbowl they're the Buccaneers
still had to go on and win more games
and the Buccaneers of the Buccaneers who
cared at the time about the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers this was about the Eagles
playing their last game in Veterans
Stadium losing that game did take away
some of the luster because it's the but
if it had been the Cowboys beating them
in that game then then you've got then
you've got something more memorable it's
less memorable because it was the
Buccaneers and oh by the way they'd
opened the next stadium Monday Night
Football the following year and the
Buccaneers had come back and beat them
again by 17 points here's a memorable
one because of the circumstances
involved as the Dallas Cowboys were
wrapping up their their long-term stint
at that iconic Texas Stadium it was so
ugly on the outside but there was always
something special about the way the game
looked when it was played inside there
was something about the lighting there
was something about the feel you knew
instantly when you were watching a
football game that was being played at
Texas Stadium
it felt next level it felt special even
decades after the 70s when we first like
wow there's something different about
this this Texas Stadium atmosphere it
still felt that way and for their last
year in 2008 at Texas Stadium they
hand-picked the Baltimore Ravens to be
their final home opponent because they
thought the Baltimore Ravens a team
they'd be able to beat so they'd be able
to shut the thing down with a
regular-season victory and everything
would be fine and they could go then go
into the new stadium and and they could
leave the stadium on a high note and of
course that was a Saturday game and the
Ravens came in and the Ravens had other
ideas and they kicked the Cowboys butts
in the fun so it was just beautiful
because the Cowboys wanted that game
they hand-picked that game against the
Ravens because they wanted an easy win
and the Ravens beat them to destroy the
party for the final game ever and what I
think is one of the most iconic staties
even though I remember the first time I
was in Dallas and the car went past and
I could see tight it's like my god
that's hideous
but inside it was a completely different
world God watches his Dallas Cowboys
play every Sunday I agree with you that
that stadium is iconic I have another
iconic stadium for my third and final
pick which has been a complete route
here know you like know you
nothing to say about my life but I know
when you like my pic you just say
nothing about it well I mean who cares
again you're picking regular-season
games that don't go ahead and matter it
like you know it just doesn't really
matter when it comes down to you don't
actually sit there and say wow remember
that Ravens Cowboys game
here's another playoff game I'm giving
you Mike so for the people scoring at
home I have now given you three straight
playoff games what's more they're more
memorable and guess what Mike what was
your criticism for my last pick the
Eagles didn't win that game right right
Eagles didn't win that game well here
you go Mike the Atlanta Falcons beat the
Green Bay Packers in the iconic Georgia
Dome in the NFC Championship Game the
Falcons a you know somewhat downtrodden
franchise other than the Super Bowl that
they went to when they beat who they
beat who they beat when they went to
their other Super Bowl blanking in 99
who was that they did they didn't they
they oh oh you're trying to remember it
was the Vikings that's right
in another Stadium that closed down you
fell right into that one but yeah this
one's another iconic ending the Georgia
Dome a lot of great events there and it
ends with a bang remember that game so
so vividly because I love watching the
Packers lose the Falcons ran up and down
the field that day the Packers had no
answer for them I also bet the over so
it was a special place in my heart
because there's nothing like betting the
over and winning it so quickly yeah you
know but it's yeah the Georgia Dome it
was only open 20 years it's got no
cachet it's got a little sizzle it's got
no balls
if you host the Super Bowl you want a
Super Bowl though but it wasn't a Super
Bowl but if you host Super Bowl you
hosted a Super Bowl that this Pontiac
Silverdome hosted a Super Bowl who cares
just because it hosted the Super Bowl at
some point in the past and that one's
not God you let me down on that well you
know what I thought you were gonna do to
me I thought you were gonna take the
final game ever played at TCF Bank
Stadium that's I thought you were gonna
hurt me I thought you were gonna select
the game where Blair Walsh went wide
left against the Seahawks in a playoff
game because that was a throwback
old-school like the Vikings games at
Metropolitan Stadium where it's a clear
blue sky but it's my
- it's below zero is what I'm trying to
say I thought you were gonna do that to
deliberately hurt me and I was thinking
about doing that but you know what if
you're gonna go chips in the middle of
the table if you're gonna go Superbowl
if you're gonna put that kind of sizzle
onto your memorability factor of a final
game ever played at a given stadium I'm
going all-in with you
I'm not hedging like you wanted the guy
to do from the other Raptors game where
he didn't he didn't dare or they were
not the R you know what I'm talking
about you got me all twisted of crows
ball the last game ever played at the
Rose Bowl the last game that will ever
be played at the Rose Bowl cuz they're
never playing another game at the Rose
Bowl that iconic venue with ninety eight
thousand people present to watch the
Dallas Cowboys shred the Buffalo Bills
in Super Bowl twenty seven nobody knew
it the last time it was gonna be the
last game ever played at the Rose Bowl
but it's the last game ever played at
the Rose Bowl and it's memorable
the Cowboys birth of their dynasty in
nineteen in the 1990s Leon Lett with his
fumble return the Don Beebe hustled and
pulled it out of his hands and I
actually won an office pool getting the
two in the seven on that from the 5217
by virtue of the cowboy he's not scoring
another touchdown that was a memorable
game and it's even more memorable now
because we didn't appreciate we know the
finality at the time it happened it's
one of those things that hey whatever
happened to the Rose ball hosting Super
Bowls oh it's never gonna happen again
well that was a pretty good time and
that was a pretty good game and now in
hindsight that's a pretty memorable
event yeah I'm writing down a note real
quick because it sounded like you
gambled illegally with that Super Bowl
square no to call the authorities
statute of limitations has passed that's
not the last game though they still play
football games there that's a total of
his last game it was the last NFL game
ever played their last NFL internet'
what it was an NFL stadium stadium and
they don't play there anymore he had
tried to get cute but the problem with
getting cute there is the Rose Bowl
still gives us fresh memories every
single year see every year don't you
think wouldn't it be great if they still
played the Super Bowl there wouldn't you
don't you think that every year when you
see that overhead shot listen I am on
the record Pasadena California January
1st that is heaven on earth I've been to
two Rose Bowls
my life it is the perfect setting for
football it was basically it's it's
football heaven but we still have it and
we still get memories from it all the
time and a fella at the NFL and that
stadium will always forever be known as
a college football stadium more than
anything so you are so wrong you tried
to get cute and he fell flat on your
face I'll throw you one more candlestick
the the 49ers were very good that year
they won it was to pick it this thick
with Navarro Bowman and of course he
also had the famous catch with Dwight
Clark and Chris Berman happened to be
there I don't know if you knew that and
Tom Brady was there and Tom Brady was
Sarah yeah
young Tom Brady wearing his 49ers jacket
so okay so we threw a couple extra in
there whether it's the picket the stick
game or the TCF Bank Stadium wide left
from Blair Walsh the last game ever
played at that college Stadium it still
has games every year but it's not NFL
games there's our picks if you're
watching on NBC s in order to take a
quick break we'll wrap up this Friday
edition to pft library reference
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports